good morning Millennials I was just
gonna say something that was gonna jinx
us and I'm not gonna say it what were
you gonna say just saying like we
haven't had like a technical issue in so
long oh wow [ __ ] together and we're like
that like when we did our first episode
like we were just like all over the
place like good for us okay guys we
don't do any of it but ya know also I
think the technical issues that we do
have we just don't really know about yes
it's like glitching shall we say it's
bliss also our audio is on point okay
recently and if there's anything else
going on just let us know but feels good
I look like I'm naked mole-rat today do
you have so many reasons one I had a sty
so I'm not wearing eye makeup because
like yesterday where I make up with my
sigh and it like accelerated the [ __ ]
out of it and like I hate saying I have
a sty because like any time I put
anything medical on my Instagram story
but especially sty like I get the most
like homeopathic remedies and I do all
of them I was had a tea bag on my eye
last night like it doesn't work oh is
that why you were trying to make tea
well no my throat hurts also but Marley
gave me her sickness yeah I was like
when I had a nosebleed and everyone's
like you're pregnant what yeah I mean I
had a nose they deferred like the first
time in my whole life which is weird
yeah and my vision was like a little
blurry but it was just because I had
this seasick oh right he's on I wasn't
pregnant thanks guys well also I've just
been like blowing out my hair so much
cuz like we just had so many simcoe's
like with the family and then like my
shows and just like I don't want to look
rose on my show and like now that I'm
like thin I like care more but it's like
taking a toll I'm like I I take pride in
like my healthy hair so I've been giving
myself a break maybe I'll do a hair mask
but now I just like puffy hair and like
no mascara and I look like the naked
mole rat from kim possible well I look
like Kim Possible oh my god do you do
like average girl Halloween I think I'm
gonna be Kim Possible for Halloween and
that would either leaves actually the
naked more at or it's just like rollin
go on his own core blood friend that's
true we were just talking about that I
would be wearing this shirt underneath
it is a crop top I'll probably have to
put like little triangles in my name oh
yeah and they have pants on Amazon I
think I ever depends Kim Possible and
then I can wear my extensions yes you
should that would be a really good
costume is it but it's like seems too
simple no no it's just like such a good
idea I can't believe you haven't done it
before right there are some red-headed
costumes that i have in like in the bank
of costumes you know eventually if I'm
ever like looking good I'll be
rabbit queue always a good fallback well
the Wendy's girl we were just talking
about Halloween because I rewatched our
episode of Halloween last year which has
been circulating because it's literally
the funniest thing ever
I mean threw it together like so last
minute and like we didn't really even
plan it and it was so epic we actually
were gonna be Kathie Lee and Hoda I
remember and I don't even know what made
us switch to being each other I think
the wigs came and were like I look like
you oh my god you look like me no it was
so funny and so now we're like saying
like should we do that again but like I
feel like that like let's let that
moment live right but what can we do I
think I guess we could think about it
yeah it'd give us suggestions I also
need suggestions for me and Ben cuz me
and Ben always go it's like this is like
iconic pop culture like my home and we
did Robin China our first year which was
like honestly best you should be Mason
Ramsay and his grandpa I know and then
last year we TG Albergo Lee and dr. Phil
which was just as epic but like someone
else had done it that same night at the
party I was at which is like so rare and
like annoyed me but I looked so good
like her and actually I found this pair
of jeans and I was like we were moving
on my bed like what [ __ ] was in here
like who's acid-washed jeans are these
and they were so small and that I'm
literally like about to yell at bed and
then I realized was for my costume with
senior goalie and like the only size but
they hadn't the story that I went to it
was like tiny and like I didn't even
button them they were probably fit me
now but I need something like just as
epic that's so funny I hate ariana
grande and Pt but it's like so basic so
basic I'm like dressing up as ariana
grande it's like I mean I would look
amazing cuz just wear thigh-highs an
oversized shirt right baby you don't
look like you're dressing up it looks
like a night on the town
yes not costumey no I would make been
like literally bleaches hair oh he has
bleach hair right now he has wait what
would you do with your hair just put it
up it's not pony and I would get like an
extension for a ponytail like a long-ass
pointer it's not enough and so we've got
the pictures from Olivia's like
engagement soiree and I sent a bunch of
pictures to Ben there's the cutest
picture of Zach white and I'm like
looking like a little cute he'd you know
it we tried and shut it it and put it in
the child I saw that you but I didn't
know why you were putting it in well I
sent it
where he's like smiling and looking down
and Ben in fact they're talking I sent
it to Ben and Ben is up the sides and
like been legit has like a huge bald
spot I saw that he's freaking out about
it cuz like Ben's dad has like the most
luscious hair like and for any man of
any age but a man up in his fifties like
has the most amazing like thick hair so
Ben's never been worried about like
that's like something like men really
worried about and he saw this picture
really where he's about it re-evaluating
his whole life there are so many things
that you can do that on early stage it's
like not even Rogaine which like is let
me give him my godness yeah they're so
good I thought and when I bought them on
Amazon I bought so many so every time
someone comes over I like give them a
package to him I will and I'm not
worried about him look at it
we'll get this under control I wonder
three boxes of tissues on Amazon and
three cases arrived I don't have space
for it that's like my apartment except
Zack does it intentionally but we look
like a storage unit but your kitchen has
so much storage well it did one right
now I can't even put my jeeps away oh my
god I've had the cable man come to my
apartment four times my bedroom table is
so nice he thank problematic and yes
sure it is the fourth one he got it he
leaves and it's on and I'm like having
the best time
litter I go to put on Bravo and it's
like you don't have any of these
channels I'm like really I have the go
package spectra I'm like it said I don't
even have channel to like it's broken I
think yeah you gotta fixed of course on
of court moving in is oh it's always
like that oh my god and for me it was at
the time of like the Riverdale season
finale Oh God and that was really a
struggle at least all you're missing is
like a random episode of OC yeah that's
true and I have not been keeping up with
Bravo's play by pay which I watched last
night and here are my thoughts I look
forward to a day when it's live because
you can feel the scripted nature of the
show Michael yo was reading off a piece
of paper and he's actually the only
comic in the bunch so it should be easy
for him and he's reading off a piece of
paper I don'ts not be like a real
brother I don't know if he's ever
watched a Bravo show in his life Brendan
Schaub
who so on our side for most stuff is the
unsung hero of the show he's just so
funny he's not he's just speaking and
he's being so funny and then there's one
other guy who's the editor of some
magazine and he's wonderful I feel bad
for Jerry because Jerry's the host so
he's doing all the bones in the show he
doesn't get to make the jokes right
sometimes you guys I love how every time
he talks about his wife Maya wives and
like I don't know if everyone knows that
that's from Borat but it's [ __ ]
hilarious Rebecca Romijn Skyped in I
don't know why they couldn't afford her
flight
um and Kelly Ripa's showed up oh she was
everywhere she was cute wearing this
season's products Kurt have you seen
that new Prada stuff wear it like looks
like almost like NASCAR the way that
they write Prada
no but that's cute it's cute yeah that
sounds cute
what thank you for asking I did musical
Monday at soul cycle which took
everything for me well sounds like a
great time Claudia it is a great time I
want you to do it just once but then I
have to like prep Nick is the instructor
and it's just always a win but sometimes
it's even better than here's the thing
then like last night was a great night I
don't even mind like the physicality I
mean he opens with Dreamgirls just why
I'm sure that out there hold on it
disease I'm not I don't even mind like
the working out let me know because I've
done SoulCycle many times and like I
feel really good afterwards and when
it's good music like it really helps
like I was in a random class and she
played honey I'm good by Andy Grammer
like it was just amazing it's that like
I literally can't walk afterwards
not because I'm sore because that seat
goes so gap your ass then it's like it
doesn't make the workout like more
intense the fact that you have a thing
up your ass like why can't they just
give you a cut like a nice seat and I
get the cushion they give you a cushion
if you need it it's not that it's hard
it's like this skinny it's not a seat
I'd say every time you like tap it back
it's like ramming up your butt yeah um I
don't notice it anymore and it doesn't
hurt me at all anymore if I do a so I'll
go for the first time in like a few
months then I get sore in my body just
seems like a weird thing but they could
have fixed yeah really on but I don't
like it's not even a factor for me
anymore but I am I understand why and
I've been on the stationary bike that
was like a normal [ __ ] seat like a
plastic one and it just it seems like a
weird thing that like they should have
like altered by now yeah ladies when she
sounds maybe one way um anyways it was a
great it was a great music great a show
straight into defying gravity straight
into arms so you can't stop the beat
straight into you'll be found from Dean
Hanson and then waiting through a window
but then Zak and I we wanted to go to
the movies so we went to I pick I got
ready so quickly I just want to say like
makeup is Magic Mike you know how grad I
got after I workout yeah
so I showered I was still so rad I put
on a layer of foundation like it was
gone magic it was incredible it's like
when you step into a pond I'm planning
when God shut Oh
Nuland is just one of those magical
think that's gonna happen to be tomorrow
we went to see night school with Kevin
Hart and Tiffany Haddish and it was so
bad what that we left in the middle not
out of anger just out of sheer boredom
like I just couldn't sit there anymore I
was like so tired and I was like I just
want to go I just want to be home I
don't want to be here and like I pick is
so comfortable it was so bad I've heard
some number-one fan Kevin Hart summer
one fan Tiffany Haddish is amazingly how
could this be bad the writing was so bad
the plot was so stupid and like slow and
every scene was just so slow and the
writing was bad like I didn't I thought
maybe it'd be stupid movie but I would
crack up a few times right oh my god it
was so bad and it's just like Kevin Hart
just gets like paid the most and he'll
do anything right I he probably got paid
so much money to do that movie and I'm
sure it'll do so well because he's in it
right
that's just so who would turn that down
but it's like I feel like Kevin Hart's
movies these days aren't like amazing
he's just like in that Melissa McCarthy
stage where like every movie you make
makes money so you do every movie right
but it's like so green like she
shouldn't be doing bad movies yet like
she's still like she's not at that level
yet she's like really on the rise and
she's like the most wanted like actress
ever that like it's weird that like one
of her big like feature films would be
like a bad one oh my god it was so bad
and then I was thinking about how like
the promotion of it is really weird
because it's on Billboard's and it's on
commercials but it doesn't seem like
it's getting any extra promotions you
know and I feel like everyone's just as
china like keep it quiet like yeah it's
really so bad I don't if these
instruments it for me to see them it
like I didn't even I don't even want to
know I don't even care what happens
whatever happened at the end like
probably just doesn't make sense
yeah like the premise is that he's
trying to get his GED and Tiffany
Haddish is the teacher of the night
school which is like a funny premise and
the rest of the classmates are like this
band of misfits it was just like so
stupid I couldn't believe it and like
Zach Zach two loves Kevin Hart loves
Tiffany Haddish and like we were both
like let's just leave we finished we
finished our meals and we're like we can
go home now
they had a veggie burger there that I
ordered and I took about it was a pop oh
my god I spit it out I was like this is
me and I was like call them over I was
like this is me and they're like no one
said I do burger I'm like I'm showing
Zach it's like Grant ground beans beef
it was it was ground beef like I tell
you the veggie burgers are like peas and
carrots and corns mushed together and
then I was like this is a meat burger
like please just take it back I don't
want anything else in there like no it's
the impossible burger
everybody who orders it says the same
thing they like brought me over the one
sheet on it and it's really a veggie
burger but like really made to taste
like meat which is just so crazy love it
I enjoyed it but I just felt so wrong
yeah why does it feel so right what is
it if being if being me so wrong why
does it feel so right okay
I think it's time to jump into the Fast
Five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of their morning toast okay we've got
some good stories for you today a wealth
of knowledge as well as I mean they well
of knowledge they don't call this most
well-rounded morning showman in
television for a reason for no reason
you know wow that was a long like
sentence I forgot one sentence with a
lot of these things yes you know they
don't call this the most well-rounded
show on television television for no
reason okay okay
first up Taylor Swift from God to open
the AMAs with I did something bad Taylor
Swift will open the 2018 American Music
Awards the singer made the announcement
Tuesday on ABC's GMA this is her first
award show performance in nearly three
years Dick Clark Productions says the 28
year old will sing I did something bad
from her reputation album Swift will
compete for artist of the year alongside
Drake ed Sheeran imagine dragons in post
Malone rap is dominating this year's
awards Drake and cardi B have eight
nominations each Sharon and Malone each
earned six nominations while Camila
Cabello is up for five
so obviously Taylor's gonna win that
award because we've learned if we've
learned anything this year it's at all
these award shows are so fake and they
align themselves with an artist like the
VMAs this year we're like Ariana's year
ariana performed ariana won the award
set like she was great but like didn't
really deserve to win especially since
her album like had just come out and if
an artist shows up to the award show it
means that they're winning something
right so it's really weird when they
actually have like Ed Sheeran winning
remotely from Ireland but because like
he literally never stops working that he
can't make it to America for right so if
Taylor Swift is showing up to your
liitle award show it's because something
big is happening because something
because she knows she did something bad
but it's like these award shows are so
fake and like based on nothing no the
actual award of the morning of the award
show was like literally the least
interesting part like I like to see
people perform I like to see people hang
out dance like talk like the actual
award like it's meaningless
no it means
absolutely nothing I guess the Grammys
and Oscars have done a good job of yes
uh you know adding like a false sense of
honour to these awards but like oh I won
the American Music Award for Best New
Artist especially Taylor Swift was like
so many Grammys like on her shelf of
awards like that ama is going to fight
in the trash that I Heart Radio or an oh
please that one reason the incinerator
years ago like I just I mean I'm looking
forward to I was like kindling I'm
looking forward to this so much because
I loved seeing Taylor at award shows and
you said this a while ago when it's such
a good point people used to make the
most fun of her because when they would
be performances at these award shows she
would like just have a good time and
like yes she's like a weird dancer but
she just like let her hair down and
would enjoy and like she knew the songs
that were being performed she wasn't
like embarrassed to sing them and like
now everyone does that but they all just
like laugh at her and sit while she
stood in like dance with Selena Gomez so
but it's so crazy how now everyone does
and I'm sure knees like thirst monsters
are out there googling the lyrics I'm of
course easy lyrics calm so that they can
get a little extra air time and like
hopefully go viral I'm BuzzFeed so it
says she hasn't done award performance
in three years and the last time she did
was where she had that really short
haircut which I was just like not not
done the iHeartRadio awards
it was Calvin had awards but she's
staying out of the woods and she was
like in the height of her reputation
tour an album and I'm 99 I'm sorry I'm
1989 and I was in love and I was like
why did she choose out of the woods
because like back then it wasn't like my
favorite no and it's really just a very
simple song you know why are we out of
the woods yet she reinvented it on her
tour and then at the award show she did
the reinvented version of it which is
like the much better version of the song
like she should really rerecord out of
the woods is the way that she did it on
the tour she like totally changes it up
and I know I know I did something bad
like is it my favorite song so I'm
really excited to see like what version
she does at this award shows to change
my mind again so in three years I'll be
like oh my god I did something that it's
like the best song ever what's your
favorite song on the reputation album um
I I recently decided that's king of my
heart oh that's so crazy to me I think
why not one of my least favorites well
first of all like that's the best okay
um and if it's not good it's my favorite
but it surprises me like every time it
comes on an album and like the song
rocks and I look down like this King my
heart like it's so good okay obviously
like getaway car don't blame me like are
the obvious choices and like this would
been like such a great moment for her
did you don't blame me like she could
have a full chorus yeah
don't but if you remember from The
Tortoise she did um I did something bad
it's a totally new version she's like
they're burning all the witches even if
you are one like it's all quietly she'll
doula shows to show off her vocal
abilities cause people love to say that
she can't sing when she obviously can
right I'm looking forward to a night and
you know what I will be watching
Michu oh my god like I just live breathe
and die for Taylor Swift and she gives
us so little to work with like Instagram
wise and just like performance wise like
anytime she actually like comes out of
her house like I have to like live do
you see her come out of her house the
other day with Joe in that like dress
dancing tried his movie premiere right I
was not feeling the look oh my god I
couldn't agree with you she looked
[ __ ] amazed I stopped like one
picture from one angle and like she is
looks like did you see it on my swifty
with no job account which is my
telescope no I probably saw it on just
showered or something no but I should
see the pictures that you posted cause
like from this angle she looked like his
mother
I guess when she like when she walked
out like her posture is just so
incredible and her shoes were amazing
and I loved the dress I wasn't in love
with her hair but her hair set this
awkward lane where she's growing it out
cuz it was so she talked to me because I
feel like I've been finding success with
my middle leg you have it looks really
she should take the nature's bounty
gummies like I do or I could call anyone
and get extensions yeah that's the
picture that I saw I feel like she looks
like a mother oh my god Jackie you're so
wrong not that like even mothers she
looks like he's out there like she just
looks matronly show you another picture
because she looks so good I want to see
a picture from the front
well she like doesn't take pictures like
she doesn't worth red carpets so like
literally she watched from the curb to
the door and they got like three photos
that like obviously are not ideal like
she definitely looked good but for like
the look of like you had like months to
plan this look she doesn't months to
plan like it just wasn't for me
her I just love her and she's so
supportive like she doesn't go to
anything but I'll go to his like fake
movie premiere because he's like a fake
actor yeah and now memorize all the
Swifty's are gonna see the movie right
right no but if there's a theory that
like she's his manager oh and that like
they're building him up to be like this
next Brad Pitt also what coattails when
is she gonna make her move about her
record label remember we reported that
yes she has until December okay I look
forward to listen
about that that'd be too interesting
like honestly it'll make no difference
on her brand or her like music so I'm
not worried but for her finances it'll
be no and I think just for the music
history I think she's gonna get some
music for the Grammys Museum right cuz
even if she signs again with a big
record label it's gonna be like the
biggest contract ever totally and she's
gonna be able to own the rights like all
of her music which is just like so
Taylor Swift for sure except this story
just upsets me because it means that
award seasons upon us I know I'm like
that's our job right like I feel this
like obligation to comment on a blog
nothing happens no and like I I'm not
gonna watch I will watch this because I
like her gym I will not I won't watch
the Golden Globes for sure it'll be like
the Oscars I find these awards like fun
to watch cuz like there aren't serious
are gonna really care about the wards it
just like I like to see people looking
cute and like celebrities mingling and
singing like this doesn't bother me
there's like no pressure around so I can
watch the clips on YouTube then I'd say
and feel like I was there yeah but the
Golden Globes are like such Pittsville
and like it's just so boring and like
preachy and like they always I got like
these like derogatory it's like speeches
where like like saying how like America
sucks but like you suck and like you're
all like crazy like the sexual harassers
and pedophiles but like we're the
problem you know they like always are
like putting their [ __ ] on us right
telling us how to limit it's like hey
we're here doing a positive morning
showing right I always get like like
they are shaming me in their speech and
I'm like you're shameful
I'm normal totally totally yeah I won't
watch a Golden Globes I might watch the
Oscars maybe watch the Grammys cuz it's
not a watch but like literally on my
phone yeah I just like oh my gosh I got
the ASEC C Theo's thick yeah he is no
he's done thick
I'm so sad like I felt oh about like we
have to run out of here after that's so
crazy because I was actually gonna text
you and ask you to bring him today
because I just needed a hit of [ __ ] I
was going to bring him today but anytime
we bring him it's like so distracting
and then I like yell tomorrow like felt
bad but she was just like trying to do
her job and she's not even here today
yeah and he's so nuts and he's sick so
like but I just like feel bad about the
evening but he probably doesn't need to
like sleep like a sick person does yeah
go to sleep but he has like diarrhea and
throwing up and it's just like so sad
and he makes us sound when he throws up
oh my god it's like the most
heartbreaking sound speaking of sleep
we're gonna get to our toasts movie of
the week later working asleep
because that's how she does which I
completely relate to him knows it was
just it was interesting
I look forward to talking about it next
story super interesting ruby roses the
Internet's most dangerous celebrity Ruby
Rose has played some dangerous
characters like an inmate in orange is
the new black and a scientist battling a
prehistoric shark in the Meg but the
actress herself is now officially
dangerous cybersecurity firm McAfee
McAfee mid-calf a the McDonald's coffee
yeah I didn't know they did
cybersecurity so diverse on Tuesday
crowned Rose the most dangerous
celebrity on the internet no other
celebrity was more likely to land users
on websites that carry viruses or
malware now listen to who else is on the
list reality TV star Kristin Cavallari
finished second on the list followed by
actress Marion Cotillard the original
Wonder Woman Lynda Carter's number four
Rose burns number 5 Debra Messing's
number 6 Kourtney Kardashian's number 7
Amber Heard number 8 Kelly Ripa's number
9 and Brad William Henke is number 20
what a motley crew I don't get it like
what qualifies someone is like malware I
don't know like these are the people who
like hackers are using to get into your
software but it's like there's no
there's no pattern between this bunch
I'm not seeing a pattern right well what
I was gonna say Cavallari and who knows
that have nothing in common so ruby bros
like when you were just saying like the
like reading her credentials I'm like
homegirl is so famous and well-known and
literally is ten million Instagram
followers like she like doesn't work
like she had like a very like minimal
role in one season of orange is the new
black like okay like Juno many
characters aren't are just a new black
like literally 30 min characters and
then she was on some show that you just
said the mega I've never even heard of
it Lisa movie whatever she like became a
part of Taylor Swift squad I'm like now
I was like a relevant for life and it's
like she doesn't even work right it's
like I didn't watch irons in the new
back I don't watch the Meg like she
could also to me like be a musician
right but I think she is actually a
musician she just looks like one like
with her tatted up oh and then she's
also in pitch perfect 3 contributing to
the worst okay guys
everywhere the movie of all time right
so it's just like she doesn't have great
credentials like a movie nobody's heard
off the worst movie ever and then like a
small role on a Netflix streaming
service show no she's famous for being
Ruby Bros which I get like she's so
gorgeous and her
like Ruby Rose right and then she was a
part of the squad so gates did he was
show up yeah interesting and she know
she really is so gorgeous and she had a
really like hot girlfriend for a while I
don't remember her name but like they
together we're just like power and
they're not together anymore no I don't
think so interesting she's on market but
anyway last year's most dangerous celeb
and she was hanging out with the
girlfriend of course that I did say last
year's most dangerous lab with Avril
Lavigne like that makes semi-god the
most sense because you're ending up on
conspiracy theory websites about how
she's actually dead and there's some
other woman singing her songs but last
year's top ten included Bruno Mars Carly
Rae Jepsen Zayn Celine Dion Calvin
Harris Justin Bieber Sean Diddy Combs
Katy Perry and Beyonce like those people
have much in common they're the most
famous people in the world like right
this year it would obviously be number
one cuz she's also the most one number
one like search person on the Internet
this year's ten includes a man named
Brad William Henke whose name isn't even
linked like everyone else's because like
there's no additional articles Wikipedia
because he's not a celebrity like all
the other celebrity names are like read
with hyperlinks but not his this is so
weird and honestly it sounds like this
company just like did a bad job
gathering this year's data right Linda
Carter the original Wonder Woman like
what did she ever do to anyone except
save lives save data it depends like
when my cell phone is running out of
data but then like let's collect the
data on the agenda suggest what is the
date on the Mackenzie file suggests
right well last I heard the data was
like all over the place because you know
Susan and an accountant in Sally we're
just on the job sally was watching the
morning toast all the time which really
who could blame her no not at all yeah
but this is a weird story and it's like
there's no resolve do they tell you how
just I guess don't Google these people
and if you're big fans like just be
careful right I mean I wasn't googling
literally any of these people I mean I
do get google Linda Carter you know once
a month I personally I do Google Mary on
Codell yard of course I mean actually
people do Google her because she's
involved with the branch aleena like
break up right right but that's so long
ago now no totally and like nobody
really cared right it's like her Sante
she's just you know what it is it's like
Brad Pitt who like presumably like [ __ ]
anything that walks like cheated on his
wife with like an age-appropriate woman
do you know what I mean right the good
friend did they even cheat I don't know
okay this next story was at the behest
of morning show host girl with no job oh
yes right
video of a camel at biggie goes viral on
Facebook and in the morning toaster
Facebook group says WWLP taco 22news I
love reporting local news like well yeah
like nobody cares and like only the
local Massachusetts news wrote it up and
I'm here to make it national force
actually we have followers in Toronto
we're going international for a second
day in a row 22news has received
messages from viewers who are concerned
about the welfare of the animals at the
Big E the new round of concern comes
after a video of a camel at the khamar
Ford petting zoo at the biggie went
viral on Facebook it appears to show a
camel refusing to get up from the ground
as its handler tugs on its harness
22news spoke with people on both sides
of the controversial video the video
shows the nephew of the khamar Lord
petting zoo oh my god a nephew Sunita's
attempting to get the twelve-year-old
camel to stand up never mind [ __ ] you
now he's me just his name
owner Tim Commerford told 22news the
animal was not being mistreated he kind
of pitched a little fit and did a
tantrum like a child would and just sat
down my nephew just grabbed a grain
instead of treats and when he decided he
wasn't getting up he just let him be
commerford said the camel he had raised
since it was two months old eventually
stood up on his own the Western
Massachusetts animal rights advocates
director Cheryl Becker interprets the
video quite differently of course both a
camel obviously was having a really hard
time standing yes he wasn't
intentionally not standing up it was
struggling and had fallen yeah
Chuckie in the video like this camels
legs are so small and foul like they
litter I know that's what I saw right so
like that's how you know this [ __ ]
lying and I mean first of all like
there's no place for animals in a circus
I'm sorry like this is it 2018 that
we've evolved like they didn't even use
it to film the greatest show in like
please and so the fact that they're
there is already problematic enough but
if they're gonna be there I had a pair
of them no in the gradation it was all
CGI in the great showmen way we're right
in sorry in 1800s yes but they also
didn't know and like I can't I don't
play right and also like in 1807 really
not not much to do other than like find
ways to entertain yourselves like now we
we are entertained a plenty and like we
have enough organizations and there are
enough research to know that like
technically having an animal like in a
zoo or an aquarium is captivity and like
we don't kidnap people like we're normal
so I see a room so right not only should
those animals not be there but the fact
that they are like treat them nicely and
like don't even say that he was just
throwing a tantrum because that camels
legs worse
so [ __ ] frail and small and like he
literally weighs like probably 400
pounds that camel and those tiny little
forelegs that have to be like
load-bearing of 400 pounds like he
couldn't do it and that guy was like
pulling his mouth like stop this [ __ ]
hairy ugly smelly guy like pulling away
this camel like and this he was just
like in this like dirty parking lot with
like all these try where I was like so
depressing and nano malware camel should
be you know of course not like he needs
to be literally in the sense he needs to
be in sex and city to when they're on
the desert Lawrence of my labia to my
labia the desert ends yeah and so but
that video came on the heels of another
photo someone this photo went viral of
like an elephant just chillin and like
you me just looked like so small and
like frail and like malnourished and
that started to like gain some traction
but like the affair happens for like a
couple weeks and it's over now so it's
like by the time it's next year
no one's gonna even remember and this
[ __ ] festival is just gonna keep
going on but so we have to protest I
mean I know we're the number one podcast
in Massachusetts we can do something oh
my god I didn't even know I thought oh
my god we can we okay everyone listen if
you live in Massachusetts do not go to
that festival if you know someone who
has been to the festival tell him not to
go anymore and comment on their
Instagram because I love to comment on
their and so am I bet you they deleted
it I'm gonna do because their post had
no know what their Instagram the biggie
let me check out you might be the big e
fair Wow
I know I'm like getting so involved oh
it's a big fail what's that elephant
documentary that we watched hug an
apology to elephants and apology to
elephants and it's like what's the
problem there were four comments and
they're all gone what's the problem with
the elephant in the room the elephant
right that movie was so sad it's like an
HBO original not really movie because
it's like fifty five minutes but it's
basically a memory yeah it's a history
of like how humans have like abuse
elephants so poorly like since the dawn
of time and just exactly how poorly they
were treated in the circus and then
there's this woman who rehabilitates
elephants have been in captivity like on
her farm her gorgeous farm in California
and like the elephants are her life and
they come turned they like literally
won't leave the barn and like now
they're all just like living and any
time like a circus retires an elephant
they send it to this woman who like
rehabilitates them and like they like
meet friends it's like the cutest thing
and then by the time the documentary
ended I believe the woman had passed
away oh my and she was like super old
it's like the saddest movie and I put it
on my Instagram story last night and
then like people are being so mean to me
it's like no good deed you know they're
like well you still eat me
I'm like okay well that's a very valid
point but I have to defend myself for
two on two counts one I only ate kosher
meat and if you know anything it's
kosher meat is kosher because it is
slaughtered in a way that is least
painful to the animal those to me right
so they don't give them drugs and they
don't like make them like bleed out
they literally it's called a shaft and
they take a big knife and they chop off
the head in 1000 and it's painless I
mean it still said that they died
obviously and as painless as can be so
that's my one defense and to like that
is a valid point and I'm just like I'm a
sister I'm starting out I'm like a new
activist when it comes to animals so
look maybe I'll get there no good
Michael thought there are animals that
eat other animals like humans eat food
chain and yes it's the ecosystem totally
that like yeah and they're like people
just like yelling at me for that but I
was just trying to point out like
horrendous hate crime you don't need a
camel no totally you don't need elephant
no I would never I just honestly Jesse
chicken yeah and like the chicken was
born so that you would eat it if it you
weren't eating it it wouldn't have been
born
yeah you know totally anyways next story
very interesting business news and the
jobs market of course course Harvard
Stanford and other top MBA schools see
applications drop looking to get your
MBA in an elite US business school like
Harvard Stanford or Wharton now might be
a good time to apply as applications for
these prestigious programs have fallen
for the first time in nearly a decade
amid a strong job market and greater
competition from programs abroad the
findings were released by the Graduate
Management Admission Council on Monday
which is a nonprofit that admits that
administers the GMAT admissions exam
throughout the country according to GMAX
data not only our mba applications for
this past spring down 7% overall from
the previous year but for the first time
in nearly a decade waning interest has
hit the country's most admired
universities basically people at less
people are going to business school
because the job market is so flourishing
that people are finding success in their
jobs and being able to pay off their
student loans so like why go to business
school it's no have a job and like I
feel like a couple years ago like what
you needed to know in business like you
needed to learn in school but now it's
like in order to be good at your job at
like a high level you need like real
life experience and like you need to
like especially in media like you need
to be in tune is what's necessary like
they don't teach you how to be in tune
necessary at Harvard Business School no
I feel like if anything business school
is more valuable than a college
education so I don't you if you major in
business though in college like you
should be getting a business school
education like Business School seems
redundant like just because College
isn't doing anything but you should like
there should be separate colleges like
if you majored an econ in college like
why do you need to go to business school
to study economy like did you not learn
it in the four years of college like did
you not have enough time right I just
feel like this is them like trying to
just squeeze you for all your course but
you know what I was thinking like greed
I was thinking so Harvard obviously like
needs more business school applicants
and Here I am just like a girl an
entrepreneur we'd started a business
like maybe I should go to business
school but I literally told you that I'm
gonna apply to Harvard but only to
Harvard Business even actually I could
[ __ ] with Wharton to know me to like
someone in the toasters posted that they
like jokingly applied to Harvard when
they were in college actually literally
have like a 1/8 GPA and she like knew
she was gonna get tonight but she just I
wanted that like rejection letter like
for her files and she actually got an
interview and she was like freaking out
you get so nervous that she cancelled
like she like regretted I would say that
she died yeah her school guidance
counselor right I remembered it really
yelled at her that she was gonna
embarrass her school so like they made
her cancel she was like I literally
regret to this day like I just wanted to
know what they had to say to me and she
posted her essay and the toasters it was
the funniest thing she was like you need
me like all these other students they
don't know what it's like to fail I do
it was so funny and then I'm like I was
so inspired I'm like I'm gonna apply
first of all I think it'll be a good
candidate like aside to my academic
track record which like isn't Harvard
material just like my life experience I
think I'm like accomplished I don't know
I was and then I told you but we were
drinking when you were we did karaoke
and you told me you were gonna go to
business school that was not apply to
Harvard and what did I say he thought it
was a great idea oh my gosh well maybe
I'll go with you we can be roommates
we should do it I would love to and then
like we could really take this thing to
the next level then we don't need a
shark because we are the Sharks
seriously well then I want to go without
you no you should if you got in and also
then like our business is run by a
Harvard Business School grad like
whoever we do the toast in Boston like I
would commute I would make my schedule
so that like we and you know we are the
number one show mustn't so yeah so we
moved to Boston for space and maybe like
this could be
Cleveland we only work Jeannie for an
MBA the only problem is that you have to
take the GMAT which is a test and like
your GMAT score it's like SAT like it
really determines how you'll do and you
know what I could take it but then I
have to study for it and then I'll have
like anxiety nightmares about test
taking oh my god I'm not taking it was
it I did so LM a SAT so maybe like I
should take the GMAT okay how to apply
to Harvard Business School is what I
Google you know Sam can help me Sam and
Katie they both took the G max they both
did so well Sam got into some of the
schools that I'm naming here and I just
actually Sam got into Wharton sorry I
was wondering if you wanted me to tell
you you need a written application with
a resume recommendation acceptance of
policies and si a Pearson Test of
English GMAT never mind I'm doing it
okay I'm gonna find out what the GMAT is
all about that seems like my biggest
turtle letters of recommendation like my
college professors or anyone who loved
me they would be so happy to see me do
this of course I'm going up to Colgate
next month so I'll just select them all
then you'll have a month I'll pick them
up in person let's do it let's do it
ship to Boston the toast and that's the
only school applying to of course
I mean Harvard or bust Harvard our best
okay cool
exciting I love when like news on the
show changes the direction of my life no
totally speaking of changing the
direction of anything Netflix is
planning a choose-your-own-adventure
episode of black mirror oh we heard
about this netflix inc is about to let
you decide how your favorite show will
end maybe it ends with one of your
morning show hosts going to Harvard
Business School who knows what like it
looks right wow we need to stop hanging
I mean that was obvious though like her
shirt I mean it was Harvard law but the
streaming service is developing a slate
of specials that will let viewers choose
the next storyline and a TV episode or
movie according to people familiar with
the matter like what this carly rae
jepsen music video idea came out like
years ago and now netflix is just
catching on the company expects to
release the first of these projects
before the end of the year said the
people who asked not to be identified
because the plans are still private
because the plans are so bad viewers
will get to choose their own storylines
in one episode of the upcoming season of
Black Mirror the emmy-winning science
fiction anthology series the show is
famous for exploring the social
implications of technology including
episodes where humans jockey to receive
higher ratings from their peers
the fifth season of the show is expected
to really to be released in December um
honestly this is so dumb like I have so
many problems with like all these
services like I've so many
recommendations like I don't have a
problem with the format like I like
sitting and just like watching I don't
need to get involved you know but you
know what like now that I think about it
there are a few films that you know I
could tweet the ending namely Titanic
keep that gorgeous wool no I I mean I
don't even know how it ends I'd change
the whole film yeah but like I would
have loved a choose-your-own-adventure
on what Rose does with the heart of the
ocean right you know yeah
but they did make an alternative ending
and it's weird they do that on like DVDs
I'm like that's fine for like freaks who
want like other options but like this is
so unnecessary like if Netflix is like
channeling their efforts towards like
alternate endings and like like
basically like VR no like do like and
it's like what there's gonna be one
option or one option you just choose one
I guess but then it's like just give me
to all the boys I left before number two
I don't need this I need that and it's
just so weird cuz what everyone's gonna
talk about the episode it's like we all
saw something else right so like how do
you get together with your friends a
recap I don't know I can see like this
is a little thirsty I'm not gonna lie
totally it's like they did this just to
make headlines and everyone was talking
about it yesterday including obviously
the most prestigious morning show the
morning toast and I truly Joe yeah and
also like Netflix here's the thing like
I really enjoy what you're doing and you
know room was available for free for me
so like keep keep it going but like try
and make some money first like I'm
really worried about you guys too like
you're making no money like why not just
put some product placement in your
movies like you have millions of people
watching - all the boys I love before
like put an ad in there I don't Netflix
it's like spiraling out of control
finance why I was like their finances
are worse than mine
like they're spending way too much money
and like now is the time where they
should start doing ads because people
like love their program so much like in
the way like that yeah so and not
commercials just like a bottle of Dasani
on the table you know right or like that
yogurt company could have sponsored tall
boys I love before or a tub it could
have been Chobani right yeah totally and
like the more time I spend on Netflix
which is less and less these days they
promote so much of their own content and
like some of its good but they have like
they spend so much money on like hiring
talent and making these shows that like
nobody Adam down there
million dollars like they spent so much
money and it's like I don't even hear
like that's the only thing I heard from
the Adam Sandler like at literally 200
million dollar deal they did what's that
terrible movie sandy Wexler that I just
watched the trailer for I just watched
your trailer for it to it's like that
Hollywood agent where I started it and
we started and then we watched the Polka
King I think we started and I watched
Jim Gaffigan we were yes yes Wow Wow
feels like I saw the movie though that's
how I feel about night school right yeah
it's like you were there in night school
that is just so weird this is like just
a highly unnecessary like moved by
Netflix I really hope they would
innovate like in a better direction one
that would make them money so that like
I don't have a pit for them actually
I've been using Hulu for the first time
ever me too because I'm rewatching
Desperate Housewives which is just so
premium and I go to Hulu on my I don't
have an account I go to Hulu on my fire
stick and I open it and I'm like texting
I was about to text Olivia because I
think that Shapiro has an account and
all of a sudden I'm like logged into
this account it's a brand new fire stick
it's a family where like the names are
Louisa Madison and something else and
like I took the Madison profile and like
made in my own eye and it's it's the
unlimited version I have no commercials
I have no idea whose account this is and
like I've never used Hulu and it's a
brand new fire stick and I just don't
know how I got it
that is so weird I started using Hulu
because unreal I guess was canceled by
the lifetime and picked up by you and I
wanted to finish it and the last season
was the worst thing of television I've
ever seen and just like really damaging
for women and the show that was like
supposed to be championing women
whatever but now I like have Hulu so
that's where I was able to finish
Nashville and just rewatch some old
shows if you play for no Zach's brother
Kyle has logins for everything because
he's an actor so like he needs to study
the craft of it I have a login for
everything music pop TV
I just finished caught up on [ __ ] sure
yeah and I got better um also
Amazon fire sticks are so crazy because
I had one way back when in my old
apartment and then I didn't need it
anymore and I gave it to some inch
recently and like now all my
informations there and homegirl is just
no barman lik it's alarming when you buy
it from your Amazon account account you
open the box and then you plug it in it
says hey Claudia and I'm like how the
[ __ ] do you know and all your
information is their babies pretend like
you on that right but no but then it
does make sense like it's my Amazon
account can you buy something off of
Amazon from the fire stick yeah like
shows no no do you buy toilet paper like
that get me Charmin oh I don't know
let's try that when I get home I don't
know I'd come to rely on my entire stick
like so much I don't even need the cable
that I finally got I mean I still don't
have people and I'm actually good except
for a CW doesn't have a live streaming
and Riverdale comes back a millennial
like I know we're cutting no but it's
it's great and now I have an app for
everything I belong in for everything
most people don't have that though so I
don't know what I would do all those
apps but you don't that you log in
through your cable provider but you
don't have one you just have it from
tile right like what would someone else
do I don't know you have to cut back on
the things that you watch right
interesting
okay are you ready to talk about room 11
toes movie of the week was room I hadn't
seen it before I was nervous to watch it
because like really kidnapping is like
my worst fear and like why do I need to
watch a movie about that like that they
didn't actually show us the actual
kidnapping like scenario right that's
Pittsville and if it wasn't the toes
maybe the week I would have never
brought myself to watch it same and I'm
glad that I did because it wasn't like a
scary movie it was there were 70 like
you had a pit the whole time anxiety is
building but it wasn't like boo you know
like it wasn't scary like that grudge um
I appreciated how half the movie was
them in captivity and half of them was
out because I was like they just get out
and now like I want to see the happy
stuff I want to see them in their lives
right you had endured all the blood pits
and then you're like I want to see the
celebration right and it turned out to
be not so happy right - that's what
[ __ ] me up about the whole movie it's
like finally I thought that I could like
give birth to my pit and it would be
over because she's out of the room but
it actually gets worse right and what's
so crazy is when they got out when
they're in the hospital I remember
thinking about like Jacob Tremblay is
gonna have an impossible time adjusting
because it's like he doesn't know how
the world works like he's seeing things
it it must be so crazy it's like
literally mind-blowing a mind-blowing
like to see a shower instead of a bath
like see like a tree that you only saw
in TVs right or you're standing in a
hospital building and there's you're
above like you're on the 20th floor and
you're looking down like that's such a
[ __ ] trip so I was like how is Jacob
Tremblay done
thank you it's gonna be impossible for
him and when like she was trying to
teach him like about how like life works
and like how the way we're a [ __ ] me
up yeah like when they were in the room
she was trying to explain it like
television is this and this is the world
and up there is heaven like that was
like [ __ ] me up because I'm like I
know how the world works cuz I'm like 23
but like it was just like it was making
me think about how like earth works
right and how unlike how we think earth
works and like so up until his fifth
birthday she like made him think that
room was the only plate was the whole
world just so that like he wouldn't know
any different and then be like sadness
yeah umm so yeah that was that was such
a bug out um but then it turned out that
like he actually was able to adjust and
like she couldn't deal with like the
mental trauma which was just was so
interesting because I thought like he
wouldn't be able to get outside but then
he started talking in therapist he's
drawing like he really is becoming a kid
no you were like waiting for him to like
crack but it really proves like kids are
so like they bounce back so fast like
especially like when they're at a young
age it's like he might not even remember
in ten years the first couple years of
his life right where's like she has to
live with that pain forever for sure but
I mean like he's obviously gonna be
messed up for life like listening to his
mom get raped every night but he didn't
really know that it was rape but do you
know what I mean but that's also the
problem like right I know Abel
definitely cut problems like he'll never
lead a normal life but he'll he baby as
affected as she was right like her life
was really over yeah and the cutest
scene in the whole movie is when he sees
a dog and he gets a dog no Jackie
he was like giving me so much life with
his ponytail and the mom like being so
just like there and even the mom's new
husband was like so oh my god when he
first when I first saw him he was like
lurking in the hallway I was like he has
to leave like that's this is gonna be a
trigger like a scary old man but he was
so nice in the patient and like oh my
god it was so cute and him using stairs
for the first time oh my god it was
truly and who was her real dad William
Mason yeah Willy mhm Maisie Maisie from
shameless I love it and it's Melissa
yes Felicity's husband he was a dick he
was but I mean can you blame him like
how can your family go through something
like that and and it doesn't
suffer and then like what things are
just supposed to go back to normal like
he clearly developed a drinking problem
like this clearly broke up his family
marriage and that's normal like she was
gone for seven years no it's just like
when they get back to the house like
before she like breaks down it's like
what do you even do everyday now you
know yeah like he made a friend Jacob
like he was like Jacob was just giving
me so much life and like it's like when
they were in the room I got the message
at the end it's like when they were in
the room like the mom kept the kid alive
in the real world the kid kept the mom
alive uh-huh it was just like I had
chills the whole time it was most [ __ ]
up movie and it was like on the one hand
if you're like a hostage and like your
cat forgets he pregnant like and that
just seems like an even worse nightmare
but like she had like someone imagined
like just being of immediately alone oh
my god when he turned off the
electricity that fat [ __ ] I wanted to
kill him I liked to I never showed his
face no they did they did yeah in the
beginning they started not to but then
then they did he was from something else
he looked very familiar but then what
was so great well then I was thinking
about so she does that interview to make
some money to pay her lawyers which is
just so crazy that that's even a factor
cuz you know why GoFundMe wasn't around
them and nobody should be like you know
what were the FBI we [ __ ] up royally
you were in captivity for seven years
this one's on us yeah by the way like
there even needs to be a trial like how
why does there have to be a trial
no it's totally like it's living it's
clear what happened yeah I think it's
like you're innocent until proven guilty
but like it's clear what happened not
really that [ __ ] me up like yeah that
there has to be a trial that there's a
there's a possibility that it doesn't go
away victims like of any crime like John
say they're like I want to deal with
this treachery
totally wild but anyway so then she does
this interview and the interviewee the
question person like who obviously who
wasn't premium and like it should have
been us but she asked a question that
really [ __ ] up jail if she was like
did you ever think like you should tell
when you had your son like you should
have given him up like had you know
captor man bring him to the hospital or
something just like let him go live his
life and it's like joy like didn't know
how to answer that cuz like the woman
made her seem selfish that like she
needed her son there which she did like
she would have never gotten out without
him but it's also like you think this
man like if you get this man a new more
maybe he's literally just gonna
they're in and burn in a ditch like you
think he would have brought it to the
hospital done the right thing
the baby would obviously have been
tested whose baby is this they have her
DNA from looking for her spur so long
they would have put it together like
that like that's not a logical thing
that she should have done she's gonna
give her newborn baby over to like this
sadist of a man and hope he does the
right thing with it and that scene where
she's rolls up in the carpet and he like
totally [ __ ] it up and like I thought
he was gonna get them killed like it's
failed USA like that part of the movie
was like that the part where like I
couldn't breathe like first of all the
guy who was like helping them was just
like not acting fast enough and then
understanding what was going on passed
up and then like Jacob tremble just like
not talking like obviously I understand
I'm just like [ __ ] speak I know but
it's like he I mean he just I don't know
but thank God that Old Nick like just
dropped him and said I'm just taking him
back in the car and running off because
like then they just would have been in
but I'm just murdered it makes sense was
that he would have drove off for good
and not come back and like kill her
right that's what I thought he was going
to do but then like at least he got out
the kid so like I was like right and
that's what she wanted that's why when
she said goodbye to him in the red like
she thought that that was what was gonna
happen like it was just so sad like the
whole movie I wanted to cry I was crying
when she ran out of course like the
police and then so then afterwards I
googled I was like joy Newsome I wanted
to watch an interview that she obviously
did after um they she came out and I
found out it's not a true story
no and it's actually based off or
loosely based off of a story from this
family in Austria I think it's like a
Fritzl family and the actual story is so
much worse so on the one I'm up to mine
this is the actual story to me it just
said move it listen no that's how I feel
so the actual story is mom and dad they
have a bunch of kids one of the
daughters like she's kind of like a
rebel she runs away for awhile tries to
become a waitress she comes back
whatever one day her dad asks her to go
down to the basement with her to help
her help him with something and it turns
like to assemble a door and it turned
out to be the door that he locks her in
with he's been assembling this prison
for her in their basement since she was
12 for six years and like the doors the
final piece he like puts like poison
over her mouth and
throws her in and keeps her in there for
24 years she has seven children by him
the mom the her actual mom his wife had
no clue what was going on they thought
that she ran away cuz like she had done
that before meanwhile she's in his Basin
had seven children by him
three of the children he brought up he
acted like she sent them to him from
wherever she was at she couldn't handle
the children the mom and the dad brought
up as their children like knowing that
they're hers but the mom didn't know
that she was just in the basement she
had four more children three of them who
stayed down there with her one who died
like right after childbirth like they
lived in like there are four people
living in these tiny quarters they had
like TV he would like to starve them one
time they expanded their cell and he
made them like dig by their hands but to
to rebuild the cell weight and then
eventually um one of the kids like has
like kidney failure and has to go to the
hospital so the dad brings the kid to
the hospital and they're asking like all
these questions all this time he was
making her like write letters like
saying that she's not coming back so
eventually they put all this together
they look at the letters they go to a
cult leader and they're like what do you
think about these letters and he was
like these seem like forced like this
doesn't seem legit then eventually the
kids in the hospital with the liver and
the mom in the cellar it's like I want
to see my child so the dad like lets
them out and that's how like they got
out to like go see the kid with the 24
years 24 years so the actual story is so
much worse so it's like why don't you
make a movie about the actual story but
then it's like you know what don't give
people any ideas like yeah I just feel
like these movies like sometimes give
people ideas of like crazy [ __ ] that
they can do how horrible is that the
Fritzl family 24 years seven children
I'm sorry how do you not know that
there's like eight kids living in a
basement sorry
like just first of all like the mom it's
like she's complicit just by being a
[ __ ] for sure or that your husband is a
psychopath yeah holy [ __ ] and that she
was like raising their children and like
three of them got to like technically
live normal right and never knew but and
then like three of them lived in the
cellar in the basement
so sad like heart 24 years like seven
years [ __ ] you Stephanie Meyer's
seven years seemed like a long time
totally 24 holy [ __ ]
so it's like just like stop making these
movies getting people ideas of like how
to you know native ways to captive
capture people right like and what not
to do like don't leave the lid on the
toilet seat cuz I shall hit you over the
head with it you know
crazy crazy Oh anyways I was the biggest
parent also the fattest Jacob Tremblay
didn't win an Oscar for leading actor
just really speaks to the ageism that
exists in Hollywood so true I won that
year
I don't know was it Leo for revenant
what year was it last year 2017 room
Oscar winners okay I came out in 2015 so
it would be the 2016 Oscars I was twenty
I think it was whoa yep revenant was was
Jacob even nominated he was officially
he was so good acting like a child who
had never seen the world like he crushed
it I never thought for a second that he
was acting like I was never like I was
fully transported into the film okay let
me show you the other nominees were no
not Jacob Tremblay Matt Damon in the
Martian Bryan Cranston in Trumbo Eddie
Redmayne the Danish girl Michael
Fassbender Steve Jobs like please and
Bri was nominated she won and she did a
good job ya know for sure he was better
he was better and like she like she was
just like a sad woman like he was
experiencing a range of emotions acting
like a child who had never seen the
world before no she like she was good he
was great he was great he was the whole
movie yeah and it's like what if they
didn't have a TV like how do you a queue
by herself for seven years having I
guess you sleep right and she would like
fall into these depressions or like she
would literally sleep for days right I
mean thank God I feel like knew what to
do when like mom was sleeping thank God
her sleep tg4 sleep the whole movie like
my body so knowing that it's not a true
story it's like they chose the direction
that it could have gotten you know he
could have picked him my backup got in
the truck and went in murdered it was
all like they did what they wanted right
and then when he's in the police car
like trying to explain how he got there
I mean thank God for the truth bit of MA
cuz he lost his letter right and it's
like he remembered that that room was in
a shed but he didn't remember that his
mom's name was joy Newsome I know for
sure for sure but like there were
moments where like he remembers and then
there's what he did he was acoustic
because it wasn't based on truth it's
just like that's just what you've chose
it's weird to make up stories like this
but also it's a book and the book is
based on that god-awful story yeah dad
I'm glad wasn't made into a movie did
not fit to me like right to my doorstep
well because when I discovered it I mean
I was just like so shook that they would
make a movie not based on they write
this story like not based on truth but
actually the real truth is way worse and
I'm just glad that they're not giving
other people ideas you know if you're
gonna kidnap someone like make it one
person in your shadow sure yeah not your
daughter in their basement for 24 years
Pittsville USA
well I think that was a great toast
movie-of-the-week recommendation because
it was a good movie relevant cuz we
loved Jacob Tremblay like felt a range
of emotion and something that I wanted
to see but I would have never brought
myself to see provoked interesting
dialogue and I think that's what the
toast movie of the week should always be
yes what should be a sign oh my god hold
on like I I have a recommendation for
the next toast movie of the week
Oh what I know I know we have a list but
I think I think I know what it should be
go Seabiscuit oh we talked about that
yeah because it's it's a true story it's
so interesting it's so good the other
ones here
AJ Michelle just really crushes it and
chuggy AJ Michelle goes inside that's
what I want sanitarium secretary Disney
one or the one with Tobey Maguire
they're the same thing to me oh but
they're but I meant Secretariat I meant
secretary there would be a lot of other
ones on here if you care well and there
are so many weeks in the year okay so
let's do Secretariat sorry and like I
said I guess the difference is that
secretary it's from like the 70s in
Seabiscuit is more recent
I don't know and like Secretariat which
one is like our jockeys to smoke our
jockeys too big and our horse is too
small I think that's Seabiscuit yeah wow
you look the one where AJ mashach is in
the play and she sings and the mom
believes in the horse yeah yeah I like
them both no that's it
Tereus oh no I know that's what I'm
using everyone I know okay I know that
that's like I know that that's
Secretariat I mean it's just like Chris
Pine Chris Hemsworth Chris Evans good
walk Secretariat Secretariat is the
toast movie of the week we'll discuss it
next maybe we should watch both so we
can discuss the differences between the
two okay that's too much work
Secretariat to start and then what's the
plan for this week
tomorrow we we are with Kevin and Astrid
which were really sad about that I'm off
to Buffalo for two shows first show sold
out the Late Show which is always a
little bit more turn still some tickets
available so make sure to head over to
girl with no job comm to clean your
ticket and then Thursday headed to
Albany show on Friday and then
Huntsville Alabama so Thursday on the
show you're doing what Heather McMann
right and Friday
Olivia exciting very exciting stuff so
we've got you covered basically are we
doing here toasters I'm having like a
furniture emergency at my house and my
owner keeps calling me so like I do have
to run okay we could do it tomorrow or
next week yeah hopefully have some good
well you guys can wait until then thank
you guys so much for being just like the
most wonderful loyal toasters do you
know about the morning toast it's the
Millennium morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on Facebook in YouTube and we're
also available in the podcast store or
anywhere podcasts or listen to iTunes
SoundCloud Spotify stitcher Public Radio
all the places make sure you're in tune
with what's necessary an you subscribe
thank you so much for listening have an
amazing day
you